[Music]
like sleeping
well i live most of my life out on
youtube with only a little channel a
handful of subscribers
i reckon they didn't like me on the
platform one bit
back then it was mostly just me
uploading short videos me talking to my
camera
i ain't had nothing but a bed sheet a
camera
a couple of microphones down there
well back then the young turks used to
make quite a bit of support to me
they teased me quite a bit
i got to the point where i could feed
hopper cheese and biscuits four times a
week but mostly i just sat out there
making videos on my channel
well one night i was doing much nothing
just tearing that to youtube
searching on a prageru video for the
electoral college
all i could find was some nurturing
makeup tutorials in my suggested feedin
so i logged into my youtube account to
see what was wrong with it
turns out every video been put in
restricted
[Music]
i haven't been unsubscribed from ladder
with crowder my favorite channel
i had to resubscribe quite a bit
but even when i did i didn't receive no
notifications
had to hit the bell three times
but then i ain't seen nothing but trevor
no videos in my suggested feed
[Music]
but then i just seen red
i hired myself a half-assing lawyer some
people think he's that mexican he's half
asian
[Music]
got home and little shaped eyes and hair
that stick out straight out the side of
his head don't matter how he cut it i
reckon
[Music]
you just puff out like that like his
pitch
[Music]
because he's half asian and whatnot
but i had my little builder go on in
that talk with youtubers top lawyers and
parlay with them about our questions on
my channel
but they didn't answer none of it
not the restrictions and monetization
they just kept asking not to spend more
money on advertising and screaming what
did you do today bain for what you do
bang debating for
i reckon that made me madder than the
whole notification business
so i had bill richmond he's half asian
some people think he's half mexican he's
half asian
i had a mark right on in this whose
mother's keys office at youtube
sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
that is the last tip of the week it's
thursday yeah all right which means it's
my favorite day of the week that means
uh it's mug club chat thursday where we
take more of your chats for about like
an hour oh geez every thursday and of
course everyone comes up with incredibly
profane names but we love you for it
before i move into anything else first
off hunter biden's laptop is real ah
the more important part about that is
remember the 50 intelligence officials
intelligence officials who said it was
russian disinformation that's what we
should be focusing on uh is treason
still a thing
uh no no i guess not no no no no no just
if you put on a funny hat and uh go into
the capital but if you actually lie
about a sitting president's son making
tens of millions of dollars with foreign
oligarchs no no nothing
nothing nothing to see here all good so
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
the incoming food shortage a lot of
people have discussed it but don't
really uh don't really understand why
it's happening here in the united states
it's both
due to foreign affairs and do domestic
due to domestic stupidity you're gonna
have to spend about five thousand more
dollars per month so let me ask you this
first thing question is do you feel
confident that you could take care of
your family
right your family your kin in the event
that uh we have a food shortage
in the event that you have to spend an
extra 400 something dollars per month
just to live
people said how bad can it get
and mo people like me i was wrong the
optimist would say well we have checks
and balances that it'll at least take a
while
sorry no i apologize it was so fast
this has happened so quickly you thought
gas was bad oh my word uh so we'll be
talking about all this pets or more yes
than no right did you just say 5 000 a
year or oh gosh does that mean we get
raises
uh well no because i don't get a raise
ah well you know what if you join my
club blowout.com club please you can
help me feed poor gerald thank you
eat as much as a small house
if houses would eat monster house that
was i'm a dreamworks guy they're still
big uh also if this uh show gets removed
from youtube because we have some things
we'll be discussing today that might not
be too youtube friendly and by that i
mean
accurate it still streams monday through
thursday at 10 a.m eastern on rumble or
on mug club just go over to rumble
nothing would make me happier than to
bust youtube's balls and have every
single last one of you subscribers go
over to rumble we'll let you know when
there's no show
if you don't see us on youtube it
doesn't mean there's no show it just
means that they don't like us okay so
gerald a is here how are you i'm i'm not
as good as i was doing a minute ago i
just got a five thousand dollar
deduction from my pay so how are you
well i mean come on man you're still
you're living in america above ground
well that's that's true that guy on cnn
has a turtleneck so he's doing pretty
well look at that
sprocket yes
now's the time on cnn vavvy dance yes
that's steve jobs
well it's the ghost of steve jobs
oh i was a fruitarian worked like a
charm yeah uh you know him you'll let me
hear him uh at landau dave on twitter
dave linda how are you good about you
ahoy i'm doing all right you got your
family too in town yes i do that's nice
yeah yeah taking my son uh to just some
events good well you know what you might
want to tell your son to uh just cut
back on the calories that's what we've
said yeah yeah feel yeah food shortage
good stuff right just yep he should just
join uh uh shortage watchers yeah we're
gonna do uh a little old yeller yes a
little bit of famine craig yep yeah
stephen this is a national diet we've
actually spread it yes exactly
all right uh i haven't seen this but
we'll talk about this first before
anything is apparently will smith
this was just given to me by the
producers i said don't watch this you'll
see it on there for the first time
apparently will smith is also a high
school track star
that's [ __ ] illegal
[Applause]
no i have to tell you i'm surprised it
took that long for that to happen i'm
surprised that the biathlon i don't get
if i'm in second place i'm just picking
off first
gold medal thank you isn't that how you
hand off the baton that's what i thought
yeah i assumed that you just punched
this guy in front of you otherwise why
would you give him a steel baton i like
to swipe more than the old one why would
you play the knockout game during the
race yeah come on well i mean it's isn't
it obvious is to win the race you get
quality you don't know first if that
guy's gonna win right
come on well hold on timeout when in the
history of man has a white guy been
faster in general i mean i mean come on
caitlyn jenner
uh yeah well
yeah we allow can you dead name in that
situation because
it was bruce that won the map no caitlyn
jenner bruce jenner even said like
bruce jenner made a joke saying i at
least i had the balls to compete with
the men and men should not be competing
with women okay this is getting silly
with all this men competing against
getting silly this is getting really
silly i mean i'm a man with fake cats
that we now know the lesson right it's
slow slow and violent wins the race
right yeah did he think nobody would see
him
i mean everybody's watching you do that
we play this again because it does look
for a second like he does a little bit
yeah i think he caught him did he get
run into or something because he looks
like he's all out of sorts yes that's
what happened he was accidentally run
into it was like my hand slipped i don't
know no i mean he did throw the punch
after i'm just saying he looked like
there was like some bumping going on
track is so boring though it would be
funny if everybody was just looking at
their phones yeah like oh what happened
they all missed well what you could do
is play this game in detroit and just
give them you know a piece of
evidentiary an evidentiary weapon
the hot saturday night special that's
true you would still get a scholarship
yes you still would absolutely get
totally fine all of you would
particularly in the women's division
when you're a man all right let's see
let me see this again
he hesitates oh no you're right no no no
running into that's a title
does he walk back over and do something
what's going on no he just keeps one
running to win what you need to do is
the punishment should be forcing that
man to run straight into the wrestling
room oh for sure and just let that team
just you know he just forced
it right out yes i kept running
yeah why police just get a
corn fed angry white farm boys who you
know couldn't make the cut for any other
team and uh it turns out they're good at
violence okay the uh researchers are
saying too according to witnesses the
guy who threw the hit was not in the
race oh he just ran onto the track he's
just like a felony streaker yeah he's
just like a violent streaker
it's like remember remember parachute
man and the evander holly feels there's
a white kid tied up in the locker room
like on scooby-doo and he took his
uniform yeah they just said he tried
getting in the way of the previous slap
and then threw that hit i guess why
didn't they stop him before come on we
have an epidemic of no security in this
country i mean william smith walked the
equivalent of what is a private jet
runway to smack chris rock this guy
makes it onto the track he didn't even
run across the track he was here's what
i do respect is he wanted to get a hit
on a guy he wasn't in on the race but he
decided to lay low for he knew that he
was fast enough to beat all the other
guys rather than run across the track
he's like yeah run a few laps and then
boom
you know what i don't like though the
disrespect that's the most it's
disrespectful that's the most hurtful
thing is a lack of respect well the
punch the punch is well the second the
thing that hurts the second most is
we've got a lot of growing up to do
third most the track when you hit it
after being punched well yeah that's the
second most and then the punch then
maybe the punch then the punch then the
punch punches first and then third is
your lack of respect actually what hurts
the most is what happened next when he
got a hold of a javelin
yes
yeah the pole vault is frilly
it's kind of ugly it was just white
track star skewers
check our privilege guys and that's by
the way that's also come on that's
that's not that's
an oxymoron what white track star yeah
that's that's not real you'll see in the
upcoming change my mind actually someone
accused me of being racist because i
said that uh in general at the elite
level
black people tend to run faster times
than white people like i would never say
that
i actually saw a clip of that it's like
you're saying black people are better
athletes
yes yeah
you got me you got me seen an nba game
recently i'm complimenting you you're
right
yes they are and we don't have any white
people don't have any sport anymore i
mean we just you know white people had
golf and then tiger woods came in you're
saying they're better soul singers yes
uh well you got me yeah are you saying
that they have more interesting cultural
dances correct yes
you got me again
you know you're right i should never
compliment you but then people get mad
if i say uh not as strong as the crazy
eastern european you know polish oh yeah
the norwegian the icelandic better to do
no those people are just the strongest
people in the world and the fastest most
athletic people if you look at all the
land speed records tend to be black also
don't punch your fellow trackmate i hope
that they locked them in a racquetball
court or my fellow trackmate
some guy some guy
some random guy running onto the track
yeah got it was he running on the track
with a hot dog
you know what i could do this didn't
even spill my food are you allowed to
hit him yeah i think i could do this
yeah yeah this is totally a fun race
it's cat night at the field [ __ ] oh all
right that admitted he's pretty good for
a guy who just decided to do it right
then yeah exactly i mean look respect
where respect where it's due okay
speaking of respect where it's due
people have talked about the great reset
i will say this
the left is incredibly effective at
moving towards things
unbelievably quickly
without concern not only for the
opposing party for the opposing half of
america but without concern for the
well-being of americans and i've always
said this in the past and i will say my
views are changing a little bit you know
you can comment below if you think that
i was just being naive
uh i don't want to be getting bitter but
i've always said don't attribute to
malice what you can attribute to
ignorance now i don't believe that
there's some master plot with just one
or two people here who are acting in
unison
but i do think that at this point in
time when you look at what is happening
uh not only with inflation not only with
gas prices not only with unemployment
and you look at
this administration praising the actions
that have led to it with no one saying
look
we get it this isn't great
at a certain point you have to say
they're they're so their heels are so
dug in they don't care if it's good for
you or not and that's contrast to
republicans for example you know donald
trump donald didn't do enough with
section 230 the internet yeah this is
these were missed opportunities you can
you see right away when democrats come
into office they're going hey why aren't
you censoring enough right away they
become more aggressive right away they
want to increase taxes right away they
decide to shut down pipelines so
this also brings us to the food shortage
a lot of people have said there's an
incoming food shortage that is true
but it's worse than you think
uh
it's a lot worse than you think and i
hate to be the bearer of bad news
there's not much of a silver lining here
that's why we have spot like prepare
with uh repair with crowder i don't know
if it's still up prepared with
crowder.com i'm not a sponsor today but
i've always said just just have have an
emergency supply ready for at least a
month because i lived through the ice
storm in montreal
you know we lived through the riots or
the pandemic where you couldn't find
toilet paper these are things that we've
lived through and right now this is the
first time in our lives where you're
going to see a shortage across the board
and it's not one of those things that is
beyond our control it is directly within
the control of the leaders who are
supposed to be representing you
okay so let me set this up with the uh
the blackrock president we've talked
about him before rob capito capito
i don't you know i don't want to get him
given the honor of pronouncing his his
name capitao we'll go with that we'll go
with [ __ ] robbie
robbie he said that an entitled
generation that's you
uh needs to brace for the shock of
shortages and higher inflation uh
entitled this is a guy who by the way is
part of a company that uh you know they
own more homes than any one large
central organization in american history
yeah and now we've created an entire
class of renters they want you
they want you to be the working class
struggling why because then you're
dependent on them there's absolutely
malice at play with blackrock and
there's absolutely malice at play with
elizabeth warren and people in
government who say blackrock is too big
to fail it is not an accident that's not
conspiratorial don't let these facts hit
you in the teeth the economist at
bloomberg they also said i think
americans should budget it's over five
thousand dollars a year wow i think it's
5 200 a year that's 400 something
dollars a month due to higher prices wow
so this is the guy that is worth 400
million dollars telling a generation
they're entitled and his company has
trillions of dollars in assets under
management give or take a couple hundred
million he's not into slash billions
slash trillion no okay good just making
sure i understand just when we were kids
we couldn't even fathom the concept of a
company and trillion underneath its
umbrella now it's just a rounding error
trillion was a fake number yes exactly
like it was like a trillion bazillion
gillian you're like ah you don't know
numbers yeah that will never exist that
was like when some kid would say i can
count to a trillion you'd be like you're
just a compulsive liar calvin go ahead
calvin let's start now i'll see you when
you're 46 yeah trillion yeah
liar boom
so uh all references available at
earthquaker.com and we'll have the link
uh pinned if you're on youtube which i
recommend you're on rumble or on mug
club uh but we'll have it in the comm
the comment that's pinned so you can see
all these references because it's pretty
important today i don't want you to just
take my word for it so
5200
more per year due to higher prices
that's probably significant to you
uh it's significant to me
it's significant to people who work here
and of course speaking in brussels last
week former vice president biden um said
that uh food shortages so we have
blackrock saying it and this is former
vice president biden trying to soften
the blow this is still the best he could
give you with regard to food shortage
yes we did we
still talk about food shortages
and uh but it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia
it's imposed upon an awful lot of
countries as well including european
countries and our country as well
here's the thing
it's one
it's one thing to say that it's another
thing to know that you are saying that
and it is directly the result of your
horrendously failed policies it's
another thing to say that know that it
is the direct result of your
horrendously failed policies and have no
shame
barely be able to get it out it's
amazing
wow just bumbled through the whole thing
at least donald trump wouldn't have
taken that on the cheap listen okay look
a lot of people telling me they're gonna
be higher food supplies a lot of people
are saying that because
because of i shouldn't say this i'm like
nancy pelosi folks a lot of people
saying nancy pelosi
she's bagged up all the ice cream supply
demand supply pelosi echo as i call them
pelosi ice cream economics a lot of
people not big fans of pelosi or ice
cream refrigerator so
ukraine russia you think it's far off
well let me go foreign as to what's
happening yeah and how that's affecting
you uh of course unfortunately that's
the direct result of policies from our
leaders here and then let me go to
domestic policy because that's something
that a lot of people don't discuss okay
so we have russia we have ukraine right
a food supply issue 35 of all global
calories come from wheat and corn let me
set that up now i know the gluten-free
people going oh no it's not about you
they always think so gave yourself a
food shortage yeah exactly i want to
give them a food shortage yes i want to
hook them up to a gluten morphine drip
do it for the common good i kind of
gluten it came with my range rover yes
is there gluten in it just
oh do you what do you have do you have
brain fog do you have joint pain do you
have psoriasis do you have rheumatoid
arthritis do you have oh you know what
no just cut out gluten really oh well
thanks oh simple that's all that's all
it is that didn't work at all
so combined uh so 35 of all calories
come from corn and wheat okay combined
russia and ukraine account for a third
of all wheat exports
a fifth of all corn exports geez from
february to march alone wheat exports
from russia ukraine right they uh fell
by seven million tons twelve percent
not to mention you're gonna have these
banking restrictions of course which
should hurt russian oligarchs we'll get
to that in a second yeah hey those
russian oligarchs are really feeling
these sanctions
uh and since uh russia's invasion wheat
prices they've increased by about a
third 30 something percent wow some
places have it as low as 30. some places
have as high as 33. i think the
reference we have here is about 31
percent the un is predicting 20 to 30
percent of the ukraine's wheat is going
to go completely unharvested in the
2022-23 season so it's going to get
worse
that means that feed prices are going to
increase up to 22 so what do we have we
have wheat prices increasing we have a
shortage then we have feed prices
increasing which will affect everything
else that needs to be fed yeah exactly
one of my buddies actually makes his own
wheat they make their own bread and
stuff just for fun like they're not you
know crazy i hate him already go ahead
yeah
his wife loves to do fun i make
sourdough for fun but they're not crazy
hippies they're actually really cool
people and no they were paying not even
they were they're paying twice as much
to get i guess one of the wheat kernels
or whatever they get to actually do that
twice as much as they paid
four months ago so i lied there is a
silver lining
that's true
you're saying that gerald's goat farmer
slash yogurt fermenting friends have to
pay a little bit more to live their
self-important lifestyle but at least
they know what it is
they know what at least they're
self-respect
so here's something that people don't
account for too of course it's going to
happen in the united states that being
said it's going to be inconvenient for
you and you know what it could be really
bad for you if you're a middle-class
family struggling to survive over 5 000
a year over 400 a month but just like
climate change
gas prices are horrible for you
inflation is horrible for you it is
deadly for people in the third world
which is where most shortages are going
to occur
facing a meltdown of the global food
system a stark warning from the united
nations that russia's war in ukraine
could send food prices through the roof
and cause severe damage to developing
economies most notably in africa
the impact will be particularly severe
in sudan which is already enduring an
economic and humanitarian crisis
it imports over 85 percent of its wheat
from russia and ukraine
the country knows food insecurity only
too well
sawing bread prices was the catalyst for
mass protests in 2019 that led to the
ouster of long-time ruler omar al-bashir
and a military takeover last year
if you look at sudan so already
you know the world food programme
estimated that over 10 million people
will be he has islands half closed like
the animals
of
drought and very high the ukraine crisis
and increasing that by 65. i am a
tourist
almost 20 million people by the end of
the year or almost half the country
being food insecure
food shortage
i like that food insecure is a fun pc
term for starving yeah exactly those
people see those people in sudan they're
almost as effective as gerald's
self-important uh friends
yeah they're gonna have to buy wonder
bread the poor best yes yes if it's
available god forbid they have to smear
it with jiff
you have to be the richest person in the
world to afford a gluten allergy
you do that should be that should be the
test for your tax bracket do you do you
have a gluten allergy you're part of the
one percent yeah we're taking 90. that's
a part of the privilege test yes exactly
these people in sudan are more
considerate more concerned with i don't
know generally not dying as soon as a
head pops off the pillow that there's
time to try and not die today
mud yeah it's not um calorie dense it's
like it's it's like hook i just picture
that it's colorful dessert earth pudding
hang around
it doesn't work that way i can only say
it so many times before all my energy
runs out so i whispered
oh good the flies have come back to my
face oh hello sweet friend at least
they're eating so 26 countries
26 countries get more than ahead they
get more than half of their wheat from
russia and the ukraine and of course
most these countries like you just saw
the middle east north africa poor
countries wheat alone it's it's like
it's almost 40 percent do you see it on
that caloric intake by the way a hundred
percent of somalia's st we are coming
from ukraine and russia hundred percent
that's that's not a that's not a typo
pirates need to diversify that's true
but you know somalia is known for being
like you know this the schmorgishborg of
food everywhere they can get whatever
they want now a hundred percent just
attack a ship that has some uh you know
has some cinnamon toast crunch on it
yeah they're gonna find one with fuel
and be like that your golden grahams are
mine now they belong to me
captain
is this a gluten ship so here's
something else too this creates unrest
before i get to the united states we
just we set it up with how much you're
going to pay but let me also get the
domestic policy before let me fill you
in on how this affects
all of us because look the war machine
is profitable
if you continually create unrest and you
have these international forms of
government guess what it makes it a lot
easier to lead people by the nose into
conflicts that they have no business
being a part of okay so food prices uh
of course they're skyrocketing and uh
they're leading to unrest in places like
you know the fun old land it's like the
epcot center
of the middle east iraq
now keep in mind you may say well who
really cares and i get it but
i'm in a battle rack well dude they've
never gotten it right not saying i don't
care about the people well you're saying
i don't care about the country such a
romantic language yes yes the assyrians
and the babylonians it was okay for a
little bit yeah yeah until they tried to
build a tower okay uh yeah so i know
someone's gonna look a little looking
through that theory i don't care about
your biblical references and mesopotamia
is it
accuracy
is it babel so remember i don't know if
you remember this remember the arab
spring that was the thing that actually
happened 2011 and uh that was largely
caused not largely but it was a
contributing factor food shortages right
that created unrest if people can't eat
they fight
something else that i want to clarify
this is also uh this is a more severe
version of what we've been talking about
for the last few years where someone
might shut down your business and people
would say oh okay i'm sorry we're all on
this together just rewind human history
a couple hundred years yeah and really
every bit it was just trading so that
you could eat our entire days were spent
especially when we were nomadic tribes
let's go back pre-industrial revolution
let's go back
pre-pre-agricultural revolution
before we had really become agrarian
guess what your days were spent trying
to eat and if some form of government or
leadership put you in a position where
you couldn't eat it was a mutiny you
killed them and then you ate them that's
what happened so scale it back you can't
have a business you can't run your
business
scale it back you can't go to work scale
it back you now can't afford to drive to
work and people say we're all in this
well how far how much food do you have
to take from someone's mouth and now we
are literally at the point where food
will be taken from your mouth arab
spring food unrest was a contributing
factor now keep in mind oh
they're palm in it right oh look at the
left hand so you know what the right
hand is doing leftist news outlets like
voice of america voices of america or
voice of america they don't even say
voices just one they love to say they
are the voice of america how dare they
how presumptuous they blamed the famine
on what what
climate change
[Music]
as the arab spring uprisings took hold
across the middle east and north africa
in 2010 millions of people fled their
homes to find new lives in the years
that followed
researchers claimed to have identified
evidence of a causal link between those
conflicts and changes to the climate
yeah because it's never been there
ensuring migration flows
the report authors say the roots of the
syrian conflict can be found in
preceding droughts and water shortages
hmm climate change you say send in an
expert on an inspector thurnberg
i don't know why your plants won't grow
it
158 degrees yes you should stop eating
plants and start eating crickets how
dare you
how dare you
just just know i'm 18 now so no one pays
attention to me
they're done with you sorry yeah we told
you it was okay hey by the way youtube i
don't care if you get mad that or villas
isn't a private conversation you can't
criticize greta thunderberg because
she's a 17 i said so when she's 18 fair
game like we prefer you don't well guess
what we just did hey youtube i'm on your
platform insulting your [ __ ]
so thank you youtube yes thank you for
protecting me for defending my tiny
breasts thank you for making sure that
we are not commenting on my eyes
so uh russia they don't just grow crops
uh they continue to make it possible for
us to grow them too this is probably the
biggest component here that they are the
largest exporter in the world or
fertilizer
there's going to be a fertilizer
shortage that seems important when it
comes to poop yeah cruel that's how you
know that you're in dire straits yeah
when you can't find enough poop
because they can't make it because
they've got food i mean guys aren't
there some streets in india couldn't you
just run like a snow plow and just
[Laughter]
a circle of life
so let me give you a couple examples of
fertilizer yeah urea is one they're the
number one producer
uh ammonia and potash number two
producer which i don't know why we're
not getting that from canada
oh sorry potash it's potash actually
you're right you know what you're right
it's potash because i'm sorry i had a
teacher a geography teacher i'm a child
that's just funny canadian geography is
the only thing more boring than canadian
history yeah unlike american history you
learn about right the you learn about
the revolution revolution you learn
about the civil war you learn about how
we fought for freedom and in canada like
the king said do this and we said yeah
all right
oh okay the only thing more boring is
canadian geography because you have
about 90 percent of the population along
10 of the border and the rest of it is
completely useless aside from mining and
i remember this is the only thing i
remember from canadian geography that
they mine
potash in esther hazy and that's because
i had a teacher who really thought this
was clever he would go hey
mr crowder if you need a trick
to remember the main
mineral exports and i'm like i don't
really want that trick i don't really i
don't like to set up one of the sweat
hogs yeah he would say so
what made esther hazy i don't really
care it was the potash
[Laughter]
but it worked because i remember it it
worked and nothing else yeah there you
go thanks a lot
you can fact check me by the way comment
below if i'm right that they still mine
potash in esther hazy canada
what a silly country can someone take
them over
now
uh combined russia belarus they account
for 40 percent of the global exports of
of potash uh the u.s imports potash from
russia belarus of course it's like six
percent uh each coming from each that's
twelve percent that's that's twelve
percent it's twelve too much percent now
this is going to harm the russian
oligarch so we have sanctions you know
on russian uh natural gas uh tariffs of
course uh but here's the thing that that
the right has always talked about it's
not just if you tax people more they'll
have less money to put into the economy
right this is what we believe people
with more free income they spend more
the economy does better it's almost like
we saw that kind of work for three years
under donald trump but i digress yeah
yeah yeah it's almost like we've a b
tested eight years of barack obama
former vice president joe biden three
and a half years because that last year
let's be honest that was just kind of a
scratch because of uh what uh the left
did with uh with the coveted remember
that was a thing where's the ticker on
cnn no no no no no no take care there is
no ticker anymore yeah it's fine now
uh
it also and then we have another uh two
years of not even four two years of
again former vice president joe biden
one of these things is not like the
other now uh though i do think former
vice president joe biden doesn't belong
the taxes aren't just about domestic
spending when you look at these
sanctions you look at the tariffs that
are taking place in russia guess what it
impacts the price of nitrogen which is
key for fertilizer production so again
you say it's only going to hurt the
russian oligarchs not only does it
not exclusively harm the russian
oligarchs by the way we'll get to hunter
biden a little bit who's making money
from the russian oligarchs to the tune
of many many many many millions also
ukraine though so he's an equal
opportunity an entrepreneur corrupter
yeah you know uh but it also affects
americans here if you eat anything
i don't care if i don't care if you're
plant-based
because you're homosexual i don't care
if you're a carnivore
diet because you're a part of the
peterson family you are affected by the
price of fertilizer so according to
nathan carson he's the vp of operations
at uh fertilizer company called chemical
dynamic he said high natural gas prices
reduction in supplies from china and
russia the threat of countervailing
duties and high commodity prices are all
driving
record highs for nitrogen so what does
this mean harming the russian oligarchs
well that's what we all believe right we
all believe it's some guy behind a long
table like oh
no
he is the now i can't use as much
nitrogen oh rats i can't do the nitrous
oxide how will i do whip-its what i just
have eggs to see but i want a pool party
yes
and if i can have a large table in pool
yes dude come on
like water ping-pong on extremely large
table that of course is unnecessary but
that's a sign of status that's why i'm a
russian oligarchy longest game of
longest ping pong ever yes that's right
sometimes we play like table
shuffleboard
but i can never reach
don't get me started on table bocce ball
yes i slide the shot down whoever makes
too many oyster shells for table so
what does this mean russian oligarchs
the russians those are the only people
who are harmed well no not only the
russian people but surging fertilizer
prices for who
american farmers here at dave morris
farms in heartland and run about about
900 acres of corn but this year the
grass isn't necessarily green it's like
a roller coaster some days you feel like
getting your head against the wall the
war in ukraine leaving farmers in the
dust jim wren says because russia is the
number one fertilizer supplier in the
u.s prices will be at least three times
higher for farmers my cost this year
will be just short of nine hundred
dollars a ton
where last year it was 220 a ton do you
think that guy like came in because he
knew he was gonna be on national
television in a tuxedo and they said
they want a more earthy look yeah i know
throw a hood on yeah you got any cards i
wanted to put on my sunday best because
i was going to be on local television
like nah put on your coveralls we want
you to look uh really grimy
said i want him i want to hit my head
against the wall the cows were like yeah
yeah ever move right
now we want you to as well i'll live
longer straight through the killing
floor every time oh you shock him
he brought in javier bardem with that
air just talking trash to the cow before
killing us so
we
uh
we uh we could face we could face food
shortages in america yeah we could face
food shortages
uh but and it's mo i will bet and you
guys can bet okay you guys can comment
below
if you think it's likely that we'll face
i actually do at this point well the
president said we will not that he's
always right but he happens to be honest
he's never hey
former vice president yeah sorry i
apologize that was me you take you take
that disrespect out your [ __ ] mouth
that's right i i it was a joke man
it was a presidential joke so if we
don't have food shortages you will
definitely be facing higher prices
a recent report from the bureau of labor
statistics says the consumer food prices
have risen nearly eight percent since
february 2021. food markets are
globalized to so to a certain extent
it's impossible to avoid the impact of
disruptions like this caitlin welsh is a
food policy expert at the center for
strategic international studies
though other countries faced direct
threats to their food supplies due to
the war
she says americans are not totally
insulated from the impact
i do think that this is going to
continue to put more upward pressure for
a longer amount of time on prices in the
u.s than if we didn't have this war it's
through increase in prices of these
inputs
that you see farmers are going to have
to pay a lot more to produce
and then consumers are going to have to
pay a lot more to buy this food
so to your pocket that is a food
shortage though to plenty of americans
yeah even if it's not you and me there's
plenty of people that that will
starve out or make hungry i mean that's
the reality of it and not only that but
if there's if everyone has to tighten
down right they have to batten down the
hatches got to tighten their belts well
guess what they're going to eat out less
we've had a record number of restaurants
already closed due to covet guess what
the uber eats drivers the delivery
drivers they're going to be affected by
guess what if they have less money
because they have to spend it on food at
home they have to be they're going to
spend less money on everything period
this is what we are talking about when
people say oh rig and trickle down
economics no no you don't understand
there's a certain point where taxation
no longer has a net benefit you can only
generate so much revenue that being said
there is a direct correlation between a
booming economy and people having more
money in their own pocket
given the freedom to spend it as they
desire and so it's important that that
is combined with affordable prices
prices for goods and services that's
what we had
yeah that's what we had for two three
years that's why an overwhelming
majority of americans who may not like
mean tweets are saying that we are
headed in the wrong direction it's the
worst polling of any president within
his first two years in history even
though he's a former vice president but
we put him in that pool right and don't
think of this as paying more alone
people will die people in developing
countries especially will die the poor
in the united states
will
die there are people that will die
because of this and we've already seen a
30 percent something increase in prices
of corn and wheat year over year again
all references available at large
credit.com this hike is added to what
and already 40-year high inflation
everyone out there know you've all felt
inflation and this is the problem too
you see that in the media you see former
vice president biden talking about it
they're saying well you know this is
something unnecessary sacrifices or
because of the inputs that we look look
how about some passion people see you by
the way people see you in washington dc
new york los angeles the same
cnn has two bureaus right so does fox
news in washington dc and new york you
guys are just talking about this as
observers
like the average american it's just sort
of this little this little science
experiment this petri dish that you can
screw with at will these are people's
lives and you can only trick them for so
long saying hey we're going to tax the
ultra wealthy more let me ask you this
if right now
right now they increase taxes
on families making over 400 000 a year
by 20 percent
right now
would that help you what would the net
benefit be for you right now comment
below i genuinely want to know that's
they're just stirring division and hate
and none of it none of it is a benefit
to you not to mention i think taxation
is theft that's a conversation for
another day they look at you the
american
the american citizen the middle class
american citizen which by the way at
this point in time is like a hundred
thousand joint household income because
of inflation if you look at the numbers
that have been changing depending on the
sources that use they look at you like
this little broken toy that they can
just fix that you know they stuff you in
their garage and they're in their den in
their hobby room when they feel like
getting to it fifty two hundred dollars
a year four hundred dollars a month
you're not feeling that
and you have to sit there and watch
someone in a think tank
talk about how all those might affect if
you actually look at uh import export
coordinators shut up
you know who else tells their citizens
we're all in this together and this food
shortage and that hunger that you have
is for the greater good of our country
stalin haters north korea that's exactly
what they tell
yeah they're citizens ask lane the brain
he knows or the mob yeah yeah yeah
we're all in this together bill gates
yes yeah
they're saying yeah you need to be
protected be ashamed if something
happened to you that's weird you could
die of starvation if i don't give you
this food be a shame if you develop this
competing slash and more efficient
software yeah and your wife burn alive
like the dead and hills have eyes i
don't know i'm just saying you don't
want to get a virus i'm just saying you
have no idea and then if you get the
virus you don't want to get an
experimental injection do you how's your
heart
that's that's what i'm going to say so
this would be one thing if this happened
and it's outside of our control that's
what they want you to believe right this
is out of our control it's climate
change [ __ ] [ __ ] and this is
also why you need to look at the people
who are trying to sell you climate
change as the reason for everything
let's say we pass the green new deal all
five pages of it right now how would it
help you
how would it help the man in sudan who
can't even afford to eat it wouldn't
change anything this is not outside of
our control this is not an act of nature
this is a this is an act of your
government playing god and you are their
subjects this is not me being
conspiratorial all references are
available let me give you some other
examples if it was outside of our
control let's say one time
fine i'll give you a perfect example
first off americans should grow their
own stuff
it should be more affordable to grow
things in the united states than
anywhere else in the world and there's
tons of farmland of course there is and
the green new deal to answer your
question if we did pass it today it
would just take more money from you for
them to waste of course and make you
spend more money on things that you
can't afford right which are now at the
highest score and it would move you all
into big cities that's a big part of the
plan right move everybody into big
cities well that's worked like a charm
how's new york doing how's detroit doing
how's los angeles doing how's san
francisco doing how st louis doing how's
insert city here well they're very
affordable too yes that's what's good
yeah yeah they're they're nightmares and
costly exactly effective it's a
cost-effective
nightmare yeah it's great that's what
happens it's really just four grand a
month that's the new friday cruise
the new freddy krueger he just shows up
in your dreams and just gives you the
new mortgage
[Laughter]
you owe me this is that 18
i'm lucky it's not yes
hey wanna refinance no so reverse
mortgage we should grow our own stuff
that goes without saying but let me use
an example cherries okay i come from
northern i come from michigan i spend a
lot of time in northern michigan
cherries are very persnickety crop so
one year when i was living in michigan
there was just an act of god where the
cherries
froze so what happened is it thawed
cherries froze cherries require a long
slow thawing winter so it's a perfect
example if you have good consistent
cherry yields
there cannot be catastrophic climate
change in that area because it's not
requires extreme cold requires extreme
warmth it requires cold winters that are
long and moderately thawing
and there have been record cherry yields
but one year what happened is the
cherries thought
then they froze frozen and we lost them
okay
now that'd be one thing that's an act of
god
but in the years when there are record
yields
the government forces these farmers to
dump them so much there's an annual
cherry festival you can look this up in
northern michigan they want to make it
happen in like the july fourth weekend
because michael moore has some gay film
festival and what happens is with no
michiganders yeah with no michiganders
there just come back it's just about and
he's just he's like i'm one of you and
he lives on was it uh emerald crystal
lake emerald lake is it turquoise lake
home nowhere near oh it's a torch lake
torch lake course yeah torch lake so
they have a cherry festival in michigan
and because they don't farm the cherries
until later in the year they have to
import cherries from florida or
sometimes places i believe like slovenia
maybe slovakia yeah but here's the thing
in the years when there are record
yields you can't say good i'll take my
cherries and i'll freeze them and i'll
use them for next year's cherry festival
you are now committing a crime the
government forces you to dump cherries
the same thing with milk if you have
milk you have a surplus of milk you're
not allowed to keep it you have to dump
it the same thing with crops corn wheat
guess what the government says you have
to dump it why
well a lot of people don't really
realize this because of the big
lobbyists with yes big farm not big
pharma big farm because they want to fix
prices due to the international exchange
that takes place aren't there homeless
people in this country
just feed them cherries milk and extra
corn and wheat and instead we dump it so
it would be an act of god if it just
happened one or two years
but on the years where we have more than
we need the government says i'm sorry
you can't you can't keep that we have to
make sure the prices are fixed why it's
for the greater good and then what
happens when there's a shortage is well
now we just have to raise prices because
there's not enough why don't you
stockpile it's an asap fable about
storing for the winner
you'll learn it when you're six
here's something even worse you know who
has the stockpiles
of all of these crops the crop of all
these uh these uh you know corn wheat
maggies which i don't know what that
means when they say in the united states
because maize means corn and french
always got confused whoops china has
more than half of that across the globe
wonderful wonderful so we dump our own
cherries we dump our own produce we dump
our own crops
and then china stocks up so we're
dependent on them oh isn't that a treat
huh it's almost like the ppe shortage
because the former administration didn't
stock up we didn't learn the lesson on
that
why the hell did i do this like i didn't
know even about the cherry thing until
today when we were talking well they say
it's because it keeps the prices at a
point where the farmers because they
care about the farmers the little guys
that are paying three times for
fertilizer right right keeps the prices
at a point where they can actually make
a living god forbid you just let them
grow and sell what they grow and you
know what the solution will be they'll
come in and they'll try and help
subsidize uh of course fertilizer now
though so we gotta step in we gotta
subsidize it more money just like let's
create the sublime uh subprime loan
market then i said well we got to come
in we got to build these people out from
the problem that you created yeah
oh yeah keep doing that to the farmer
and see what he ends up making with
fertilizer right yeah exactly like
they're making a ton of money anyway
increasing from 200 and something to 900
that's insane for them you don't
understand that that's like that's like
taking a margin that's five or ten
percent at the end of the year and
saying we're going to cut that in not in
half because you're taking profit away
from them you're probably going to take
almost all of it yeah right or probably
that guy the guy from wisconsin is
paying four times what he paid last year
that's insane yeah you want to pay for
this not to mention what he has to pay
for in helmet fees just to knock his
head against the wall that's true well
and then robert wright comes out and
says these companies should just absorb
the price increases they shouldn't be
passing on higher costs to the consumer
and that's the real problem is these
corporate greedy people out there like
you're you're an economist you worked
for the united states government at one
point why does it apply to the farm why
does it apply to these corporations
being greedy and not to you
government representatives i've never
understood that why is it greedy for me
dave gerald to want to feed our own
family to keep her own money but not for
you
to take it so you can believe that all
of this
as you experience this and
look
i i wish i had better news for you i
really do so that's what the only good
news is if you've been watching this
show if you're a member of mug club uh
you've been hearing us for a long time
say you need to be an autonomous human
being you cannot rely on the government
be ready for an emergency i'm not saying
there's going to be some kind of nuclear
holocaust fallout but what i am saying
is you do need to diversify
your supply your personal supply 100 you
need to be ready to be comfortable with
the uncomfortable if you're prepared for
that you are better off than most people
in this country but let's assume because
right now the the right sort of the
the talking points they want to send out
the narrative that they want to set i
hate you i was looking for any word
other than the narrative to set but in
this case it's entirely appropriate is
that all of this is outside of our
control so let's say you believe this is
an act of some cruel nature's cruelest
trick that or
or
due to
international policy which by the way
goes all the way back to installing a
government in ukraine due to
international policy sanctions due to
tariffs that we placed and due to
international relationships due to a
global government and us not being
autonomous because that would be racist
we've now all of a sudden cut off a good
portion of our supply not only of food
but of energy to transport the food the
fertilizer to of course obviously help
create said food which affects all of
our farmers therefore you negatively and
you're going to see gas prices you're
going to see food shortages and the same
government when there is a surplus
rather than allowing it to be passed on
to you has systematically told
our agriculturalists that they need to
dump them or face penalties so it's an
act of it's an act of god it's chance
or maybe there's something more sinister
at foot and i don't think that it's some
meeting that takes place in a hotel i
think you get people like joe biden who
haven't lived in the private sector that
man has not earned a dollar in the
private sector
since
carter was president
people like that who get into power
never relinquish it and they just seek
to gain more power that's all it is
that's all the conspiracy is it just for
a sociopath
to be a sociopath we usually think that
that means this person has to have you
know bodies in their uh nancy pelosi ice
cream freezer they don't
they can store a lot of bodies they just
need to be selfish
they just need to not care about how
their actions affect other people and
you can be a sociopath and the damage is
just as bad and right now you do have a
country run by sociopaths and when i say
that i'm not just saying it because i
don't like people
i'm saying it because of the results of
their behavior and you bear the brunt of
it 5 200 a month and sorry
sorry west africa hope uh hope you can
deal with your record starvation deaths
speaking of deaths and not to be a
downer we'll get to some other stuff
here but uh you know i did this segment
as a see well c mathson did this uh did
this uh academic conference on fat pride
um
so i have to be care i'm just going to
tell you that this is very sad actually
when we did this
seminar this was actually about a year
and a half ago this conference
c matheson was this transgender fat
pride activist you can go and watch the
video we'll link it below
uh who was peer reviewed and was asked
to peer review and one of the featured
lecturers at this conference was dr cat
pause
i thought it was cat paws no i didn't
want to be two on the whiskers so cat
pause
died uh march
25th so just recently here since the
video was released a fat pride activist
at this conference uh she was
eulogized in new zealand's the gossip
gist
here's a quote massive university
academic doctor da cat pause die
suddenly
on in march 2022 her death news was
shared by congresswoman mp deborah
russell via her twitter account i know
very few details except that our darling
friend died in her sleep last night i'm
so very sad and i know that many in
academic and union circles will be
shocked and saddened too look
you can look up a picture this is
someone who was tremendously overweight
yeah and they're saying they have no
idea i'm pretty sure that i can guess as
to what contributed to it i hope that
you understand something
you can read more examples of this with
thousands of transgender individuals by
the way 42 attempted suicide rate
with fat pride
with the modern gender theory with
putting kids on puberty blockers sure we
make fun of it
sure of course we we have to draw
attention to how absurd it is
but ultimately it's because it's it's
it's harmful and it's not only harmful
to it's harmful to these people
we're treating these people as though
they're all brave and beautiful when
really the reason that we do what we do
is it's like drug addiction it's not
good to tell someone yeah keep no you
know what keep eating
fat pride is fine no you know what yeah
cut off your penis and and uh you know
we'll we'll cut in a you know
we'll cut in a jack pumpkin tim burton
vagina it'll look great
we'll you know what no yeah we'll suture
up your vagina and put on a and we'll
put on puberty blockers that we know
that uh of course could uh cause
hormonal imbalances and lead to uh
increased cancer but i don't know it's
whatever you want to do this is the
problem that we're running into so my
heart does go out to the family of dr
kat pause
and i wish that i could have i wish i
could say that i didn't see this coming
but that's exactly why we do what we do
so if people think that the left has a
corner on empathy sure maybe we go a
little too far with a joke sometime sure
going undercover and what i will say is
a masterful troll job may offend some
people the left's policies
create death
from food shortages
to not only abortion right all the way
up until including birth
to praising fat pride
to praising modern gender theory
this all if you can't see the direct
the direct a very straight through line
to the leftist idea of not disciplining
your children
you're looking at the world incorrectly
hey no you know what you're massively
overweight it's it's not healthy hey you
know what no it's actually not a good
thing for you you just think that you're
a boy but you're not how do i know well
it's biology we can test it
hey no you can't have that cookie
just letting people have whatever they
want is not compassion
you end up with kids who are monsters
and then those monsters become
presidents and congresswoman
and professors that's why we do what we
do yeah all right
uh you know what actually gerald before
we move on to hunter biden this has been
bothering me all show you're you're
supposed to be wearing a shirt from the
merch shop to plug this crowdershop.com
the terrible shirt yeah
take it off i got it you have one okay i
got one right here look like a hobo yeah
you can take off your shirt i got a
merch uh for you
that's in your contract you have to be
able to uh to promote the uh you need to
be able to promote the show this is yeah
all right i agree
oh
what's wrong oh no oh my god no what is
happening god what what what what is
that why would you
why do you have why is it different
colors but
what are you a mutt in every first off
here's your shirt i'm not italian
what part are you is it every this this
oh don't call me fredo it's disgusting
oh
you should think about manscaping oh i'm
never having dinner with you have you
thought about manscaping here you know
right here i think i have uh here's uh
if any catch is gonna be heavy
oh nice cat there's the acid in my mouth
from the last three vomit
consider using that trimmer oh look at
this guy yeah try it yes manscape what's
the website i don't even know oh
manscape.com go to manscape.com use your
promo code credit for 20 off your order
free worldwide shipping put on a shirt
oh okay sorry yes well you said try not
right now
not in the company of decent human
beings so uh manscape is actually a
sponsor to the show i've actually used
their uh product for a little bit um you
know why when i had surgery they had to
shave everything before the surgery so i
had to use a trimmer i said what's a
good trimmer the manscape trim and then
uh it grew back gray
yeah well once you do that at
our age yeah it's not there's not uh
there's not your old color underneath no
i think it was the stress though of the
actual of the surgery you ever seen
comes back great does it come back right
i've uh i've shaved to the old uh parts
yeah you ever
i don't know i should say this but you
ever come across because you can shave
all parts by the way you ever come
across your first uh testicular hair i
have that's great see in the mirror it's
like you hear the theme from schindler's
list yeah you look at it here
playing in the background
this thing has a nice little guard yeah
it does actually it is very honestly for
your but
you know what you guys let me know i
don't i don't obviously i don't trim my
body hair look but that being said i do
uh when i do heavy squats i have to wrap
my knees and i used to have a hairless
patch
only around my knee in the back of my
knee so i use the trimmer to just sort
of even it out because it looks weird
looks like i'm wearing a stripe you
could really full tom sell again yes yes
so uh they do they have all kinds of
great products and they have the balls
to sponsor this show and really you can
have uh
more cleanly shaven balls if you want to
sponsor the show the lawnmower 4.0 is
great just go to manscape.com crowder
promo code 20 off your order also by the
way me and dave we're going to be on
tour may 14th tulsa oklahoma june 18th
pikes peak uh center in colorado springs
there are a few tickets left at both of
them definitely worth it just go on
instagram see the reviews and dave is
going to be april 8th april 9th in
juliet illinois and then the genesee
theater in waukegan illinois but more
importantly since we've gotten through
these plugs
is uh jeffrey epstein's pedophile island
just went up for sale really lord yeah
really i know what would you guess the
price tag
free that's what i was going to say yeah
does it come with bleach yeah
gotta go yeah
it's just haunted right yeah do i does
it if i buy pedophile island do i also
get snake island so that they can
destroy pedophile islands i hope so no
what do you do with it price tag and i
think they're a little lofty 125 million
dollars i don't i don't know i don't
think that's lofty i think island should
probably go for a little more than that
yeah but thousands of people weren't
typically raped on those islands that's
true well yeah okay i was okay i was a
little confused but we actually have
we've we acquired some if i'm not
mistaken exclusive footage from the
auction of where the island was oh it
starts at 125. yeah okay
all right our next item up for grabs is
jeffrey epstein's gently used sex island
i hope you're all excited about that i
know i am we will begin the bidding at
125 million that's 125 minutes now do i
have 125 million do i have 125 million
125 125 oh bill clinton i just want the
picture of me and the blue dress back
for my mantle okay all right do i get
131 30 million 130 million one thirty
million one three million one thirty do
i hear 131 31 oh pete townsend from the
who
i'm doing research for a book your
bloody wanker
whatever you say all right do i hear 135
135 135 one another if i not two now two
now two they're charlie sheen
winning i knowingly gave several women
aids
that's why i don't think you have the
money all right do i hear 140 140 now do
i hear 141 49 141 1142 oh
dan schneider from nickelodeon and head
of the class
throw it to your feet shoes are staying
on all right do i hear 145 145 145 do i
hear 145 oh paul rubens pee wee herman
my kitty pouring his vintage
okay gross all right can i get 150 150
now 150 do i hear 159 159 159 now two
now 159 oh
six perverts from cnn there's uh
so very many of we perverts at cnn
that's for sure all right super 155 155
right here 150 now one now two now one
video 160 160. 160. go ahead once you
have 160 160 what souls and mr bill
gates
that place is my disneyland
[Music]
oh wow just can't stop with the mrna
injections that bill gates really i had
a feeling he was gonna buy it yeah
i thought he was just gonna he was gonna
buy it and then by the way he's not
going to pay for it i doubt he's going
to steal it yep oh that's what he does
to get his money that's exactly what he
does to get his money gosh you're
probably gonna be like yeah here's an
iou that's as good as money he's as he
he's what an evil disney character used
to be
right yeah but now he's the hero
now he just looks like he drives his
subaru to softball practice yes exactly
yeah tells you to eat soybeans and lose
why does every billionaire have a
terrible haircut have you ever noticed
that you have a billion dollars i think
it's because that's how that's how they
get a billion dollars is there uh you
know they're frugal they bought a
flowbee yeah
sucking my will to live joke's on you i
just use a popcorn bowl yeah i just
i just hold my head sideways and cut it
straight
[Music]
all right uh we're going to talk about
something going on in sports but let me
just hit this and then we'll go to mug
club chat which is always fun little
cutter.com mug club and honestly you
know i don't plug these things that much
with you because uh
uh you know you always feel dirty
plugging some but just it's that's the
way we make revenue mug club lot of
credit.com 69 of your students veterans
active military 99 you get the whole uh
you get the show no censored uh content
you get an additional one hour of show
each day as well as the entire blaze
catalog okay so let's move on to hunter
biden a lot of people are just saying oh
hunter buy no okay the laptop sure we
know that that's not news but there's
more to it than that remember how we
were just talking about this and earlier
this month former vice president joe
biden
he was talking tough
on the
russian oligarchs in amy's diner he was
gonna take it to russian oligarchs
our interest is in maintaining the
strongest unified economic impact
campaign that
on putin in all history and i think
we're well on the way to doing that
in the state of the union address i
announced that the department of justice
is going to after
the crimes of russian oligarchs the
attorney general spoke to that earlier
and who lined their pockets with russian
people's money and
while ukraine and the people are hiding
in
and
subways from missiles
that are being fired indiscriminately in
russian cities fact check they're hiding
in quiznos now we all know you see it
he said they're hiding from missiles
that are being fired
in russian cities yeah are any of the
citizens hiding in russia no i think you
meant ukraine sir you have your
countries confused yet again well you
say tomato he says dementia now
here's the thing the laptop has been
confirmed true and by laptop i mean like
three correct yeah
[Applause]
there's a musketeers of left yes exactly
one for all and all for child porn yes
oh no now uh you know who else raked in
millions of dollars don't get don't get
me started
uh on the man the man behind the iron uh
hard drive yes the man in the iron hard
drive indeed
there's that movie they just add a
fourth musketeer yeah
you can't do that okay you're not
welcome you're not welcome here it ruins
though it's three three is the magic
number here no
you know who else raked in millions of
dollars not all of them from foreign
entities and russian oligarchs
hunter biden he had three and a half
million million dollars from uh elena
botterina the wife of the former moscow
mayor i don't i believe that qualifies
yeah maybe well it kind of went right
back to russia didn't it yes will
charlie boy i certainly think that
qualifies four million dollars was paid
to hunter and devin archer while they
were serving on the board of barisma if
you guys don't know you know something
something ukraine hunter had a lot to
contribute to that board yes he did yeah
yeah yeah he threw a few guns behind
their grade school dumpsters
stupid
and when people say oh hunter biden's
not president he's not the only one who
was involved in these deals not to
mention how much of a liability he is
not to mention his father the former
vice president currently serving as
whatever in chief joe biden
lied for him and said that the stories
weren't true
now hunter here's what's also important
not just the kiddie porn not just the
crack pipe not just the smoking parmesan
cheese hunter had these incredible he
had lucrative business dealings with um
uh is it is it
is that how you pronounce it
the chairman of the chinese energy
company uh cefc now keep in mind cefc
was a major player in president xi's uh
landmark the belt and road initiative
that was a huge like one of the biggest
projects yeah yeah tightening your belt
because we're building roads and we have
no money to feed you don't you love how
they always tell you to tighten your
belt and their leaders are fat pricks
it's true
their belts tighten but it's not because
they're doing it yeah those tanks are
hanging on your life
[Music]
tighten yours too
we just keep sewing large labels into
the triple xl shirts oh well thanks yes
thank you for telling me that we're all
in this together kim jong-un
thank you for telling us that
we have to invent sizes for you yes
no still large yeah we would you know it
would be great if you could have a
seamstress on staff but you killed the
only person who could create a 52 short
stupid
now 50 too short and ridiculous the
parachutes i need for a collar okay
all right okay fine you see you
just kill me i'm fine with it so hunter
he had business dealings uh the mayor's
wife russia barisma we're now up to uh
you know seven eight million give or
take uh the chinese communist party he
had numerous dealings with chinese
nationals linked to the ccp uh all
together and this is from a report you
can read this right now at senate.gov uh
resulted in what they said were millions
of dollars in cash flow now here's my
thing
okay so you have burisma okay so you
have the millions of dollars with the uh
former russian mayor's wife okay so now
you have the russian communist party uh
sorry the chinese communist party and
you have this money
many many many millions of dollars right
this is at senate.gov so this
investigation was going on for a long
time but anybody who knows anything
about the process of investigations is
you reveal some information pretty
quickly uh it didn't take long you just
had to ask for hunter biden's ally bank
records by the way his password was one
two three four five crack and it's
pretty easy to figure out there were
four
there were no not 40 there were 50 50 50
former intel officials 50
claiming that the hunter biden laptop
story remember that it was
russian disinformation just in case you
needed a nail into the [ __ ] coffin
of this idea of russia russia russia
donald trump guess what nothing donald
trump had nothing to do with russia
former vice president joe biden
well we see millions of dollars 10 for
the big guy former vice president
biden's son well we see tens of millions
of dollars not only russians not only
the ukraine but the communist chinese
party who by the way have the world's
greatest supply uh or sorry surplus of
grains and produce uh to whom we will
now be beholden so 50 members
of our intelligence
of our intelligence officials let me
just be clear about what that means you
could have people from the cia the state
department you could have them from the
fbi you could have them from the nsa we
don't know exactly who they are because
a lot of them are 50 intelligence
officials so no no this is russian
disinformation
is treason still a thing
genuinely
you either have to believe that the c
the cia fbi the state department they
are all absolute morons
who the only fact-checking they would
have needed to be able to do is just
watch this show i'll get to that in a
second
and they said it was russian
disinformation you're gonna tell me they
weren't doing the democratic party's
bidding when that was a story that came
directly from the democratic party you
guys all know about the steele dossier
guys all know about hillary clinton
paying off operatives we all know that
this is true this is not even being
denied the media has confirmed it but
our intelligence officials
who are supposed to be looking out for
the security of you
lied to you
about arguably the greatest liability
that any sitting president
has ever been baggaged with
is treason still a thing
i don't know you come does it require
some blue face paint and a funny hat
going on a tour of the capitol i don't
know you guys comment below and if you
comment also smash that like button if
you can because that helps with the
algorithm and of course youtube will try
and for the same reason they got rid of
the dislike button they'll try and make
sure that nobody sees this and i'm
getting a little worked up so we'll go
to the mug club and say are you
incompetent or compliant i mean that's
really what it breaks down to i don't i
mean i'm sure what do you want to be
called because you're one or the other
you're either yeah
let's go with incompetent i'm going to
go with things let's go incompetent we
started out targeting donald trump with
the russia disinformation stuff all of
these agencies came out and said yep
this information is accurate yep we're
going to act on this information turns
out that was not true then it comes down
to an election that's really close and
this comes out when it was absolutely
relevant and could change the election
you know we know for a fact it will
change the swing states yes and here
think about how scary this is
because i'm going to get to a clip of
rudy giuliani on our show where they
show the the hunter biden laptop for the
very first time
at this point
at this point the fbi they weren't even
interested they came in and took
everything from rudy giuliani's house
except for the hunter biden hard drive
no yes that's true um before the
election you had facebook twitter
right they well twitter completely
removed the story yeah facebook and
instagram throttled the story we saw
direct results here on youtube where
they would throttle the story if we were
talking about hunter biden because they
said they were trying to cut down on
disinformation and conspiracy theories
and at this point the intelligence
officials said it was russian
disinformation so the fbi cia people
looking out for you they say this is
disinformation then you have the biggest
companies in the history of the world
alphabet youtube google uh twitter
facebook instagram really five companies
who control the flow of 95 of
information across the globe let alone
this country say all right we're taking
our marching orders from the
authoritative sources that are the
intelligence officials they're telling
us it's russian disinformation and so
poof like a fart in the wind it
disappears before election and now
everybody is saying we were wrong about
that are there any consequences yeah any
consequences whatsoever this is why this
it's not about money when bernie sanders
tries to talk about the ruling class
it's not about money anymore you have
plenty of billionaires who are very
charitable i know some people they're
good people
they're upstanding members of their
community it is about the elites who
seek nothing but power that's the them
in you that's what washington dc the
white house the media and the media
entertainment industrial complex our
intelligence community and big tech now
how how do we connect these dots the
oscars were just sponsored by pfizer and
biotech i believe and guess what
they work with the city they have
complete liability right uh protection
from the cdc and you're not allowed to
speak out against vaccine you're not
allowed to speak about accurate
statistics on covid we had a video
banned we were suspended from youtube
for two weeks that's why you go over to
rumble you go over to mud club we had
clips of our show removed
or we can see directly throttled or
slapped with warnings when we were
talking about the hunter by laptop story
which was banned at the time on twitter
on facebook on instagram based on the
authoritative information
of [ __ ] artists from the cia and fbi
are you starting to get the picture all
they needed to fact check was watch this
show you can see this right now the
media is acknowledging that this is
correct
rudy giuliani former mayor rudy giuliani
on our show on a live stream revealed
the laptop for the very first time and
it shocked us have you seen the pictures
have you seen the pictures of him with
the crack pipe
did john right i have oh wow does he
look at least look like cool
unfortunately i can't show them to you
right now but this is the hard drive
they're on right there oh my word
let me ask you this uh mayor giuliani
how did you get that hard drive because
this is this is the crux of the new york
uh the new york post article being
thrown right on social media they said
that you've been working with a russian
agent uh or that it's entirely false
actually i got it directly from putin
you are not going to believe who likes
his pipe
again putin sent it to me
and he said um
i don't even know he actually just
wanted a couple of bottles of vodka in
return so let me just walk you through
this that happened on the show okay and
at this time the story was still being
declared misinformation
i don't know if you remember the
sequence of events it was banned uh from
all social media and the media didn't
talk about it was a blackout we know
that would affected swing states by
polling voters of swing states
that's how terrifying it is what did
they do
at first they tried to say that it was
illegal
that rudy giuliani hacked a computer
yeah now hunter biden was so high that
he just left it at a computer repair
shop
then they tried to say it was russian
disinformation that's what they stuck
with through election
until the vote until the record number
of votes for the most popular former
vice president ever joe biden came in
and then afterwards they say you know
what sorry we were wrong about that
contrast with if we get one fact
incorrect on this show one and sometimes
if we even get them correct but it's
damaging enough that youtube doesn't
want it we lose our livelihoods
forever are you starting to see the
picture are you starting to see the
imbalance of power and by the way
we don't have direct ties with the fbi
cia
or the state departments we don't have
that protection good thing susan
wojcicki has him on speed dial and jack
dorsey for crying out we're at a point
in this country where
something's something's got to change
and i don't blame you i don't blame you
for being mad we try to be happy
warriors on this show and i am generally
i think that the world is a better place
tomorrow than it was yesterday but
something has to change hopefully
there's hopefully there's a red wave
that happens in the midterms sponsored
by kotex and hopefully everyone out
there starts taking an active role in
your community and you can start by just
leaving a comment below smash that like
button but right now we're going to talk
with you on chat on mug club and uh get
your thoughts which i'm sure are
probably a little bit fired up youtube
you know how i feel about you
so